welcome to this video coverage for round
three of the same field and yeah we had
an absolutely spectacular round this
time and I'm looking at all games a
little bit more closely but I cannot
really do a full coverage for all of
them then the video would be very very
long let's start right away with vasila
graph MVL against Levon Aronian yeah
where she started with the loss or not
say withdraw and the loss so then minus
one well Aronian won his last game
against Apollo yeah we have this opening
night f3 and g3 yeah often leading to
her Ettie type of structures and VL
normally plays efore playing a very
sharp theoretical lines but once in a
while he switches to less theoretically
explored lines just to get a game and
this is what we will see here aronia
plays g6 interesting choice Bishop g2
Bishop g7 this is also in my line as
black heavens that I play so interesting
interesting to watch yeah and the idea
of this early g6 is that black here in
this position is basically threatening
to play e5
so if white goes just castles then e 5
and but black is just having a good
center here it's sort of like after
let's say D 397 later 96 it's like the
purpose defense but reversed so black is
very comfortable white has to do
something about the 5 and normally plays
C form or deform c4 can be answered by
c6 by D form or by taking as Anand
played in the World Championship match
last year against Carlton yet d4 is the
other choice and after that we will
transpose to an apparent fianchetto
Gurunath out here Aronian played c6
interesting little move order ring
you can also play Knight f6 of course
you can
it's a totally healthy move which my
transpose to our game but c6 has an
additional idea the idea of the early
success if white should play c4 early
like let's say after this castles Knight
f6 this is what happened if white plays
c4 now black in addition to castles can
also consider to take and this is a
pretty interesting option maybe you even
get in b5 to cover the pawn this has
happened and it's not clear if this is
really a good line for wine therefore
white plays Knight BD 2 preparing c4 but
this now has limited White's options if
he would have been able to play c4
earlier he could have played many other
setups then with Knight B D 2 however
this is the normal line that's nothing
special for black here blacks main moves
are Bishop f5 and 85 yeah a5 is designed
to anticipate b3 so that after b3 like
will have a 4 available b3 is the
natural way to prepare White's further
development and Bishop f5 is also a very
normal looking move it prepares nighty
form to exchange some pieces using the
defense Aronian played Bishop e6 which
seems to be a less common with only a
couple of examples that are found b3
yeah this fits in any way Knight e4 we
should be to know we trade it yeah in
this position now Aronian decided to to
change the the pawn structure and alter
the pro instruction and i'm not quite
sure if this is a good idea I mean to be
honest I'm questioning the whole thing a
bit with Bishop e6 but what I'm pretty
sure is office that
what we get into a free move is just a
terrible position for black I'm not
quite sure though what he should play
maybe yeah well the problem is let's say
you go 97 a totally normal looking move
then 95 is coming and here you don't
have a good response
what are you playing now why they're
threatening to take on e6 and destroy
your power structure and if you just
move the bishop yeah wide is going to
just take the spawn and dead wide wins
just like that
it's it's not so easy here to play a
normal move yeah Knight a six maybe I
mean this is not a great spot anyway but
you're still running into into those
ideas and you know these ideas it does
not does not feel totally harmonious
with blacks having here maybe h6 try to
prepare all that but white is definitely
more comfortable the bishop is simply
better on a5 let's just imagine this
position with the bishop on f5 then you
could relatively easily play Bishop
before in this position you have put it
on F or maybe exchanged it play six but
somehow this does not feel right
he now captured here on c4 and after
Knight g5 for you and you're in trouble
what are you doing with your bishop now
if you move it somewhere or let's say
you you cover it with Queen d7 them to
avoid the double pawn something like
this it's definitely an attractive
position for white d5 is possible or
just the capture yeah the idea is that
after the Queen takes d5 leads to a very
promising position for white you have
big big edge in development here and
this Knight is especially problematic
let's say after this why does
immediately threatening to take him
we've got a huge pressure here something
like this for example I know it's a deep
line but it shows that this is a very
persistent pressure
let's say here 97 and it transforms yeah
all the time
now the rook is on the seventh it's just
not very good he took on b3 and now the
white of course grabbed on his six Fe
and now Queen is free good news
amazingly enough this position had been
reached two times before it's just I
just think that black is terrible yeah
and very very tough to defend especially
in a in a practical game the comp is not
so pessimistic it only gives white 0.6
0.8 around this around this range but
it's just totally ugly like gets a 6
gets taken White has two bishops on an
open bought the center and open France
on the Queen side to to put huge
pressure on black yeah he took on a to
know this and this yeah just just easy
easy moves for white you have a diamond
compensation here black of course cannot
take because of this kind of deadly pin
yeah II five III and although yeah he
went rook f5 on the more natural looking
move is 97 here but it's also not really
yeah leading to something great for
example d5 there are many possibilities
but d5 is the most straightforward c5
keeping things as close as possible and
then just as an example
shake and droop to be one yeah it's a
fantastic compensation Knight b6 for
example here here yeah and the ship to
h3 coming to e6 this is not a forced
line but it shows that white has a
tremendous position here for his pawn
it's it's absolutely absolutely a pester
to try to defend this stuff look f5 was
tried maybe trying to confuse matters a
bit MV I went look FB one yeah here even
d5 was was possible already the idea is
to take on g7 and Queen B to be seven
right away this is also very strong
after the capture here one key point is
that inserting g4s x is an excellent
move blacks rook now is in big trouble
why should it go if you return here then
this line is it's already Jack totally
winning
d5 was was even a bit more forceful but
White's compensation is so great it's
it's I don't think black can defend this
honestly yeah he went Queen b6 now which
did not help but what what should you do
now let's say you go night a six for
example trying to develop this again d5
is a strong breakthrough now let's say
here takes on on g7 Jack's is the best
year or the easiest way to play and here
yeah black will lose will just lose
material here it's not possible to keep
all this together
he went Queen b6 mmm II for back the
ship c3 attacking the Queen it needed to
step back and now Queen B 2 we are
attacking p7 and forcing b6 and now d5
you know in term here we have a pretty
forcing sequence Black has a hard time
not to exchange so did that check
King here and now if I if that's very
strong pushing the center forward
attacking c6 yeah here there also was a
bishop h3 looking at quite nice let's
say h6 and then continue from there it
should be six check King h7 also a very
attractive position but I think what
white played here was was totally fine
and just hear it here getting the pawn
Knight a6 that Queen b3 Queen b6 now one
the b6 pawn but black head said
absolutely no alternative yeah he
continued for a bit but white some
advantage is just far too great the c6
pawns supported by the bishop it's too
much initiated this is counter play with
the apron and after rook c8 Chandru qg8
resigned the game it's it's of course
easy now let's say King here you just
take on a two rook takes c7 and white is
promoting yeah this was a total opening
disaster for Aronian somehow this this
whole set up here when we came to this
position was was not not working
probably he needs to do something else I
really feel that this position is is
almost unplayable for black I mean maybe
maybe I'm wrong but I think this is just
a terrible position okay let's look at
the next game both players are 50% now
so in the middle of middle-of-the-pack
next game to look at is to power off
Nakamura let's say let's see here to
pawn off Nakamura okay - Paul off efore
and we have we Lopez yeah now can we
were playing
relatively classical opening we have the
neo of angle variation or sometimes
called the to catch if she rivairy ation
one of those lines where the the naming
convention is not totally clear okay C 3
D 6 a 4 would be 8 or this has been
played yeah hundreds of times here to
Paulo played Age 3 this this is totally
normal looking you for the Rui but in
this particular position it seems to be
quite a rare move only one or two
examples that I hadn't in the database
um yeah it just prevents Bishop G form
so it just does make some sense of
course like castles okay another thing
black never can take here because of
this little trick very useful to
remember yeah castles deform Bishop to
b6 rook e1 Bishop d7 all very normal
looking moves right now trade it and
went night a3 that's one idea of white
setup with an early a force to put early
pressure on this pawn very often black
gown does not defend it but sacrifice it
he however I can where I decided to play
differently it took on d4 2985 yeah
getting this Bishop protect the bishop
you definitely want to keep also you
want to protect you for it was attacked
twice by 9 in Bishop so before attacking
the knight on a3 and this does not have
a good square needs to return does not
look right but on the other hand black's
knight on a5 is not brilliant as well
Ruki 892 going through this pretty
quickly there's lots of things to look
at later b3 good move Bishop b1 yeah
white should not take definitely
cause this is certainly a trade that
black welcomes trading and the somewhat
sick be porn against the e4 pawn so this
should to be one now Queen to d7 yeah an
interesting position here it's um it's
yeah not clear what what white should do
actually um should he just continue with
normal ruin like moves yeah it's not so
easy if you play something like this we
were just blundering inform you cannot
really move the knight on d2 and if you
cannot do that how are you going to
develop c1 or get the bishop moving on
on b1 not easy at all really two part of
decided as he is not the kind of person
to shuffle around it's easy to shuffle
around by the way he decided to play at
the movie 5 just play aggressively as it
is in his usual style however it's not
clear that this really is a good move we
see em Y takes takes and now Knight age
5 this was necessary after the
normal-looking move Knight d5 putting it
in the middle of the board white is just
taking and wins the pawn for nothing
tonight
h5 ok yeah this looks a bit like putting
it putting it on the edge of the board
and technically it is but black has
ideas to activate the knight Knight f4
and also sometimes 93 and note the the
pin here so um this is not a bad term a
bad spot at all for the night so what
does y do he played Knight to g5
continuing in this aggressive manner and
at first I thought well isn't this isn't
this just a big mistake
what employed Bishop takes f2 yeah in
fact
camera could have played that yeah
Bishop takes f2 at first we need to
appreciate that white is attacking here
and here so there are threats to black
but there is this idea Bishop takes f2
let's look at this Nicola didn't play
that move but this was definitely a move
that needed to be considered it seems
also after looking at it a bit with the
computer that it is good for black but
the the lines so complicated and and
difficult that I definitely understand
why the camera may be shied away from it
let's look at let's look at the lines
yeah at first you think okay white must
take in fact that's not the case let's
start with white taking this is in fact
not a great move Queen d4 check this is
of course the point if white now plays a
King move checkmate one purpose of the
night h5 move is revealed checkmate yeah
rookie three needs to be played and then
rook takes e5 seems to be good for like
note that White's position is yes
there's lots of pins going on the knight
on D 2 cannot move now so you cannot
easily protect the rook on e3 it's a
really amply unique situation yeah he
probably has to play this move Bishop
reform after which black can take on g5
and this here yeah it's a funny
situation I mean so many pieces look
look offside yeah almost all pieces are
unprotected by black but white is pinned
very much pinned here the knight on D 2
cannot move probably Queen b3 and here
we can take stock black as a pawn up and
probably just has a good position it's
not easy to evaluate beforehand but it
seems to be good for black however the
amazing thing is after Bishop f2 white
does not really need to take
he can play king h2 and this is not not
clear at all
what should a black do now King edge -
at first it looks silly I why not take
the look the problem is after the rook
capture it is in fact white who is
getting the best of it white can take
here the King f8 Queen takes h5 and this
is a huge attack yeah don't forget that
this Knight is also hanging and it's a
little bit can easily be forgotten but
the big thing is that Atticus is super
strong yeah let's say Luke takes good
night here and Bishop f4 coming this is
in fact according to the convent almost
winning attack it's a little bit
difficult now to look at look at all the
lines but why this is in very good shape
him yeah Bishop F - Bishop Dixie one is
not the solution so what should like do
yeah he probably should think about move
like Queen d5 setting up a
counter-attack or very difficult to to
see and evaluate in advance the capture
probably King f8 and now I move like
Knight d2 f3
yeah this jack in fact Bishop g3 note
that if black takes Queen takes a one
leads to a great position for white
those things are very important
Bishop a one looks like a totally normal
move but in fact it is not not that
great
f5 is hanging and after something like
this White has ideas like Bishop b4 or
Queen h4 and this is a really really
substantial attack also something like
this if we go here and then let's say e
6y the tank is enormous
yeah I've got these ideas you know I am
a very very difficult position for like
to play the computer says just equal but
yeah it's a different thing looking at
an engine evil and play this over the
board very dangerous position for black
in this line
he shouldn't probably take on he won but
play Jack the bishop check King h1 and
then probably Knight see for this is
this is if you believe the engine very
good for black and the computer is
rarely wrong in this kind of messy
position but it's a depth very different
thing to him to to evaluate it over the
board as a human player Nakamura didn't
take on f2 yeah I couldn't see the press
conference would be interesting to to
know why he discarded it I mean I
understand that it doesn't give a clear
picture for a human player but it's
sometimes interesting to see where where
they they stop their their calculation
and said okay well I'm not going to go
with this but I don't know exactly do to
do to witches to do to which position he
decided to play g6 at the end covering
the h5 not now white can play a six and
he did and Queen g-form yeah this has
definitely activated why it's pieces is
got active night and active Queen and
you also have ideas to further improve
your knight on d2l this is so definitely
in terms of activity of progress for
white the position however is still
completely fine I mean black has no
problems Knight f6 getting the knight
back in the middle of the board and rook
f8 putting some pressure on f2 instead
also a move like Bishop g5 was a good
choice putting this bishop on a good
square covering here and covering here a
good alternative in order to play knight
c6 later after Bishop
centralized him also good but Luca it
was it seems okay only a couple of moves
later we reach a very critical point
night df3 Bishop 3595 so why does a pawn
down but she definitely has compensation
for it
Queen g7 and now why played the move
Bishop to d2 around here it gets again
very complicated technically yeah Bishop
b2
there also was something like this
intending Bishop h6 leading to an okay
position for wide after Bishop d2 here
black had an interesting opportunity
that he didn't that he didn't take he
played knight c6 it seems that here
Knight h5 was an interesting move
it is however SL is was with the
complications of before very difficult
to evaluate after Knight h5 the computer
suggests after giving it some time that
Knight G takes f na g f7 should be
played that looks weird but what what
else is there Bishop takes f2 as a
threat if white plays a normal-looking
move like this like it's just going to
take him you know note that now after
this there is this oops there is this
greatness very nice very nice Knight
takes Queen takes b2 and we have a
double attack
yeah like night here rook F 3 and on f2
this also an attack this is a totally
crazy variation typical computer chess
it is okay for black but who is coming
to who is going to calculate this it's
very unrealistic this is one reason why
Knight h5 is interesting yeah the comb
also gives this crazy luck is crazy move
here I can show you
line that is giving it's just totally
totally weird takes takes takes here
yeah looks crazy
wait this it gets better um night age
six Jack King ever made check here King
g7 this is not totally forced yeah but
just just a very very funny variation
rook takes a five okay yeah if Bishop
takes Jack get this leading leading to a
draw yeah draw like this and we have
from Bishop d2
g4 g5 those ideas like and also after
Luke takes a five can also take here
after which White has the crazy move
group c5 attending also Bishop c3 now if
black now takes we just recapture I'd
have this idea yeah very very very weird
stuff now the computer gives as the best
move the funny moves rook f8 attacking F
2 which is answered by Roxy - it's one
of the craziest lines that I've seen in
a while probably here what what's the
next line it's very hard to memorize
something like this Jack and here we get
an absolutely we attend game where Black
has sacrificed the two exchanges for
pawns and I rather be black but okay
well this is a totally crazy line and it
shows why sometimes computer evaluations
need to be a yeah taken with a grain of
salt because well who is going to
calculate this kind of stuff no one
night at try forever was very
interesting and maybe write him
he went knight c6 and the problem with
this move is that it probably was played
with the intention of playing exactly
what was done in the game and this is
recently not good
white captured and now on a camera just
recaptured it turns out that this is
absolutely yeah
probably even lost for black it seems
that after 1986 he had to play he had a
strange move Knight h5 again this
counter-attack don't get me wrong I'm
not saying he blundered or played
terribly it's just that this position
requires such a tactical accuracy that
this is only BM this is something that
only a computer can done it's very very
easy to to to make a mistake as a human
player yeah as mentioned f2 is hanging
what should should white do yeah maybe
maybe Bishop to e3 yeah we should be
three and here black can take and T is
okay again yeah all this is depending on
on little tactical ideas something like
this yeah and coups counter-attack it's
a really complicated position he had to
play Knight h5 with this counter idea
this is after rook takes Bishop f2 this
is the idea and wide also yeah just know
it does not have many alternative cm on
f2 you can maybe maybe cover this like
this and continue from here it always
has this counter attack this is why also
Knight d6
it's not really good here and now too
much stuff is hanging d2 + a1 yeah super
complicated
he went with this and now to power off
just played Bishop c3 yeah and it turns
out that this move is is leading to
probably a yeah unsolvable problems for
black now the knight cannot
from f6 this night h5 idea is out of the
position and probably black is lost here
it's really really that bad of course
there's a thread only six yeah so um
yeah this this move that tries to cover
is answered by rook takes now if white
takes with the night then this is not so
clear and I probably even that is clear
white can still take some other idea
yeah he went rook takes that's also very
strong note that this is hanging on c6
he didn't when troop takes this the line
but rook takes is also very strong with
the idea to to use this de special so on
the h7 pawn you know so there's also
this idea to take him yeah rupee it
didn't help Nakamura played he five
after which rook takes e5 was played 95
he tried this as a last last attempt
yeah attacking on f2 and looking at the
c3 Bishop but white had had a good move
in reply Quincy form setting up this
counter pin yeah and this in fact wins
black now took on f2 that is just a
check King to h1 yeah now black is
collapsing due to the the multiple pins
there's also Bishop reform to increase
suppression he played this move
desperation Bishop takes and Queen takes
and we should be form this is the the
big point this this Bishop is also
helping and increasing the pressure c6
hangs and f8 hangs rook f6 and rook d1
yeah the d5 Knight is the problem
NTM Nakamura resigned a very complicated
game from a technical point of view many
many combinations and enforced lines
possible and very easy to to go astray
for both players yeah certainly a very
important win for to Paulo after the two
losses two losses two losses in the
first in the first two rounds and yeah a
bad result for Nakamura who maybe should
have taken on f2 but yeah it's um it's
um yeah very difficult very difficult
position okay now let's look at the game
of the round
Calvin Kawana the world champion with
two draws probably not very satisfied
yeah he didn't play a play bad chess or
anything but certainly would have liked
to get a win in a canoe and Kawana with
with two two red wins so Carlin
certainly eager to try to to level this
and and even this even the score two to
get on equal points with kawana
let's see what happened and cousin
playing efore d5 okay yeah Clara wanna
place a place and number of openings but
if five is one of his main moves and
Bishop c4 interesting choice normally
what goes night a three year of course
and if he wants to play the Italian game
there is little reason to to not do it
like this
in fact one motivation for Bishop c4 is
that you avoid the the Russian defence
of Petrov defense this is not into in
part of koalas repertoire though so this
remains a bit mysterious
why exactly Bishop c2 and c4 here was
chosen
maybe after Knight f6 d3 this was played
maybe cards and after knight c6 really
was planning to to do something like
Knight c3 here
sort of giving it a Vienna game flavor
maybe it's hard to had the same koala
didn't play 96 by the way Bishop c5 is
also a good move here this is Serge this
is a move that I play but not so not so
often chosen um he went c6 this is also
well known of course and usually the
choice of those players who normally go
for the petrov as they now get a
distinct position not transposing into
the Italian game and therefore also
avoiding a little bit of theory yeah
blacks ideas to quickly play d5 and we
see that after Knight f3 d5 black gets
in this move Bishop b3 yeah here it's
important if black decides to take after
Knight g5 is in to try he's in trouble
we have f7 not a good choice yeah
black has has some some choice he can
play and it's a 5 Bishop d6 I can play
check this check a good move karana
played that rather rather quickly
what's the idea yeah one idea is that
very often after a move like Bishop d6
white is going for this type of setup
Knight c3 put pressure on d5 sometimes
supported by Bishop g5 and what white
wants is to provoke this move which
leads to quite nice position really this
is a very good diagonal maybe you get an
F for later and also play C 3 pretty
good position so this is some pressure
on d5 and this is the motivation behind
the smooth white now has to yeah
misplace one of his pieces or exchange
it let's say Bishop d2 black can simply
take this and say okay this has helped
me exchange some pieces to make the
defense easier or white can play this is
what Carlton did you can play c3 and now
B should be 6 this Knight c3 idea now is
it's not possible anymore c3 is not in
itself a bad move for white but it has
somewhat limited White's possibilities
Bishop g5 was no plate and this is the
typical cards and movie has a soft spot
for this pin in the in the reuleaux %
and Italian game structures it looks so
fairly normal however if we go here
Bishop h4 Queen to e7 yeah it's looks
looks like a normal move 27 90 to 97 all
very normal
yeah we however pretty quickly come to a
position where I'm not quite sure what
what white should do let us look Bishop
g3 not played by by Carlsen Bishop c7
this is a pretty standard move that
wants to prevent Knight c4 with the
tempo on the bishop and now in this
position he castles
an interesting choice and taking after
some consideration um one point here one
one question is what about this Bishop
on g3 what it is what is it doing it's
putting some pressure on e5 but if v is
very well fortified this Bishop also is
in constant danger of being yeah
dangerous maybe a bit a bit much but of
being exchanged with Knight h5 which
just gives black the bishop pair with no
particular compensation for white yeah
counsel with this next move is basically
deciding on a very very risky very risky
business I think what he also could have
done is alternatively to play move like
h3 to have the h2 square window but if
Knight h5 comes I'm not totally sure
about that the thing is he cancelled I
will show you what I mean now can wanna
play tonight h5 not playing castles for
example this is
after castles white s I mean not a good
move is a bit much but this is less
convincing why place this move and has
those kind of ideas in the game not very
comfortable for Black Knight h5 is is
much stronger yeah
now black just wants to take this bishop
and term yeah it's it is very
comfortable for black if he manages to
do so so let's say white plays a normal
move like a queen e2
black will take and just play something
like this and now this is a position
where he really has very little to fear
white especially like some any active
plan what it can try you can try
something like this but this is just
exchanged if everything else fails with
the bishop or black might get in
something like g6
King to g7 to to cover those squares
black is not having a huge advantage
here but he has absolutely no problem so
it's a very easy position to play as
black cards and decided on a very risky
strategy he now played the move h3 this
is very interesting but it is very risky
as well the problem is of course that
black can take on g3 and he should take
on g3 if instead he's playing and let's
say castles then white can retreat the
bishop and somewhat question the
positioning of the snide yeah there's
even the direct threat Knight takes e5
him black instead of this of course he
took ever takes yeah and we see that of
course white has taking lots of
structural risk giving up the bishop
pair he's weakened the dark squares
immensely III g3 this is all very weak
but what he has in return of causes
pressure on f7 here with rook
Bishop and he's got this idea which
looks dangerous
in this position now Khurana decided to
do in a way go for it as it was clear
what was happening castling was possible
but after that night h4 looks quite okay
for what yeah nothing brilliant but it
looks it looks okay to me there is this
idea Knight f5 and 96 black can't play
something like this for example but I
think here white
definitely has let's say compensation
yeah we can always call it like that
for Bishop and structure he's got lots
of activity going maybe this is
debatable I mean probably black hairs
also came Khurana ever played 95 and
after this move it's clear what's coming
and this was already of course planned
beforehand when come when cars and
played castles he now sacrificed on f7
he spent a couple of minutes still to to
decide of decide to play it but it was
clear that this was the intention behind
this this concept of giving up the
bishop here to to to wreck the pawn
structure it must be something very
direct yeah
Bishop takes f7 very nice what happens
now yeah the first thing and easy to see
is that Queen takes is not playable
after Knight takes we have this attack
on the Queen and after the Queen moves
there's Queen h5 and black is destroyed
yeah something yeah like that is going
to happen you must take with the king
yeah which runs into the fr Knight takes
e5 double checks and so on yeah in fact
here's the first interesting position
cosmonaut took on e5 with with a double
check there also was Knight h4 in more
interesting than you first thing um did
the idea is that you get to g6 just as
you got to g6 in the game but the
diagonal here is closed
yeah of course you haven't taken the
pawn but still this is a big difference
this matte light might lead to the
following night h4 King g8 must be
played I cannot go here jack this again
losing and then 96 yeah the idea is to
play rook FA just as it was in the game
Queen back and now Y can win the Queen
with Lou gave a and it might lead to an
okay position for White Queen takes
Knight takes King takes and now probably
Queen h5 going for activity yeah with
rook everyone coming maybe Knight f3 h4
again it seems that after we should be
60 f1 king e7 Knight f3 this position is
not totally p.m. I understand that
probably yeah
if anybody black is probably better but
it's not a totally clear situation white
has definitely some play against the
king with 9h for coming a computer gives
black cam a slight advantage but this
can only be a gap part of the tool let's
say it's a very very complicated and
hard to evaluate if you have only
limited time to analyze cards not ever
took on e5 back King g8 and now 96 this
is a different thing now there is this
diagonal this is open and Queen g5
therefore was played this of course has
the idea to you're here or here with a
counter ten on the dark squares black is
not defending a passively here at all
look if ain't now split jack looks very
normal
instead we also need to check Knight
takes but after that black has more than
one good move even Bishop takes h3 is
good but you can also just take here
with this say if I've trying to close
this and B should be six here we see
that this night is going to get taken
and black still has a good attack em
yeah II five is also a weak pawn there
also wants Bishop takes edge three
misses also also quite interesting put
it mildly
okay it is better to play this check as
Colin did King aged seven now a very
very peculiar situation yeah the rookie
can be taken in two ways the the big
thing it really is that black has a huge
counter-attack if white takes with the
night and well he did that let's look
the other thing first rook to yes and
something like this black has two pieces
for for the rook but he has the
initiative let's say something like this
before
check and here's the counter-attack yet
in this funny situation white cannot
take here because of Bishop takes h3
this rupees is also hanging and we also
threatening to win the Queen so
something like this Jack and black wins
very tense situation of course maybe
here we can look at other moves than
before
but I think black has a good position in
any case neither three maybe just here
and again we have this thread coming
what white can try to exchange here to
not get made it but after this we're
probably facing a bad end game after
Bishop move coming Black has two pieces
against rook and pawn but he's is well
coordinated and has chances to maybe win
the e pawn in the process this can only
be good for black
this is what comes up late 1988 and at
the moment who should forget he's an
exchange up and two pawns but this is in
fact not the only thing going on in this
position blacks counter-attack it's very
very strong
he had a choice he could also play Queen
III but he decided to play the fleshy
move Bishop g4 which is strong and and
also as mentioned very very nice-looking
yeah developing with the tempo to g4
this Bishop yeah what what's happening
here the rook is also attacking him if
white takes on g4 just grabbing this
it's easy
black will just take all this and at the
end he will win the the unlucky knight
in the corner breaks just the piece up
and wins the game you cannot just take
with the Queen so what should why do
it seems that Carden smooth was the only
one he played the Queen to everyone yeah
here we have an interesting moment if
black had had some choice of lions that
all look promising he played the most
spectacular looking played 93 living
another piece hanging on d3 there were
other other ideas a relatively simple
continuation was Bishop e2 I know it
looks again a bit a bit flashy but it's
clear that after Queen takes rook f8
we're easily winning as the knight is
dropping so white really must play Queen
a5 yeah there is no choice and after
this we should be 6 it's clear that only
black can be better he has this
discovered ideas so white cannot rescue
his knight King H 2 rook takes and black
here is definitely better with two
bishops
against Luca and two pawns and the e
pawn is not very strong this was a
relatively safe continuation
and certainly okay for black but Kawana
played the most spectacular with 93
which was probably probably also good I
say probably because as you can see it
is a wild position and maybe even as the
combination of human enter and the
engine is not enough to evaluate it with
limited time yeah lots of things are
hanging let's go one by one
quint ext3 was the the game move one
point is that if you take this black is
winning easily get to the check here and
9f2
yeah and this is this is disastrous of
course something like this check check
check
one way to get mated so white here must
even give up the Queen you cannot take a
edge this is the first thing what else
can white rhyme if he takes them on on
g4 there's Queen f2 check let's say King
here this yeah and again this check
proves to be deadly Jack Jack can first
take take some stuff yeah yeah yeah and
so on there's more than one way to win
this like it's just winning the house
here probably can also made somehow but
I didn't see it okay taking on g4 is not
not working yeah after a while the
combats the the toughest defense
suggests the funny move King h1 but this
also does not really seem to help like
at least can do this and play Bishop to
e6 covering f7 and now he's got all
those attacking threats something like
this is again a safe way to play yeah
forcing the Queen trade and then picking
up the night at the end with a very very
good endgame for black he's got again
the bishop
again you get two points while this is
of course a problem it would be
different if those pawns were were
connected like this pawn would be on f3
now this is a big difference but this
way White has lots of weaknesses and
it's just worse just one way to play him
I'm not sure maybe Black has something
something better against King edge one
there certainly enough to to investigate
he went Queen takes d3 rook takes a fate
was played and now H takes g4 yeah we
see that at the end here the material
situation would probably be if not equal
this night will get lost but in the
process White's the structure of course
is amazingly bad karana took on g4
Knight f3 very normal move trying to
improve the the king safe team yeah the
the comp suggests Knight B 3 as being
better but it does not really change
very much I think Knight f3 Queen takes
d3 d5 King takes h8 and yeah around here
maybe white can can defend better it's
clear that white is on the ropes he's
got a bad structure very bad dark
squares and of course the main point the
King safety is is very very questionable
it seems that in this position Luke f1
is a tougher defense so at least from a
from a purely purely a technical point
of view however it is a very it's not a
great great move to play oh you love to
play there are many ways now for black
to continue it can even consider just
taking only 5 but ok
probably it's better to keep pieces on
the board and try to continue with them
yeah with activity against the King
something like this for exam
can be played getting this idea or
especially this idea in the mix the
computer gives something like this as a
line jack now very a very problematic
position for white he can try to stay
active something like this and this is
it seems really more tenacious than the
game however it's not clear that the to
this will save him the game after six
yeah there was this in this coming again
attacking this and also threatening this
rook maneuver to get the last piece into
the attack plate Queen to d6 Luke t8
Queen back Luke t5 that's it the rook is
coming over the fifth rank Zack check
King age seven yeah Luke age five is the
big the big threat
yeah in this position now count plate d7
Jack Queen age five check yeah Luke age
five also needed to be considered but
you don't really have a good move after
this and the Queen is protecting the
night and he ate Freddie a dis is also
threatened so this wasn't a good
solution Queen h5 is better and here
cousin made the gather that saying the
decisive assist too much he is lost
anyway but he went night h2 which loses
relatively easily Queen h2 was a little
bit a little bit more tenacious but
after Queen e8 we see that it's not
possible anymore to really cover this
pawn
yeah let's say rook e1 there's Bishop f2
intending Luke edge five wins
and if you try something like g4 to
cover this black can pick up the porn or
play this and this as you want this is a
winning position for black the white
king position is just too bad and on top
of it he's got a it's got a pawn he went
here and after this is very easy where
after check takes tanks and after Knight
f1g he was losing this piece as well
King h2 giant queen g1 and here the
world champion resigned yeah okay King a
stream like this picks up White's last
hope maybe you can also made white but
okay picking up the opponent's enough so
of the fantastic result here for car 103
out of three and he won against thousand
again with black he also lost the number
of games against card but he's one of
the players who definitely managed to
beat Magnus quite often this is a great
great achievement I mean just askin
Nakamura never won a game against cars
with classical time control and kawana
I'm not sure but he has got a number of
wins probably half a dozen or so maybe
more I'm not sure calendar has more
notes or lots of games he wanted to loop
yet for example against can won over the
black but it definitely shows that koala
is a big threat to Carlton in the future
and maybe in the present but he does not
have a match coming up he has to qualify
for her championship match but at the
moment that it somehow seems that he is
yeah even if it's only very another
points difference it seems that he is
his world number two really it's only
got a couple of points more than Aronian
but from the let's say the threat level
to the two cards and he seems much more
dangerous in a way so a fantastic start
for him three out of three 1000 is on -1
so this is not good he definitely needs
to to get get wins in
and better quickly yeah let's see what
happens maybe he's also a bit distracted
by this by this [ __ ] negotiations about
the World Championships a match to be
held in in Russia later I'm not going to
talk much about that I'm not very much
interested in those chess and politics
issues okay I hope you enjoyed this
coverage on these were three three great
games the video got a bit longer but
it's very difficult to do something that
at least resembles an analysis in less
time yeah thanks for watching